I'm Torsten Wiesel.
I'm a neurobiologist
and I'd like to talk about some discoveries
that David Hubel and I made
starting out sixty years ago.
And this picture is from when we started out.
David Hubel is to the left and me to the right,
and we had just finished our medical studies
and decided to leave the clinic
and try to see if it could not advance our understanding of the brain
by doing basic research in neuroscience.
And the... we were very...
our attitude was very much the one of an explorer.
We just had tools in our hands
and we were interested to understand
how we visualize images on the retina,
how they are being processed by the brain,
so we can see things in detail and color and that.
So that was... and no one really had, at the time,
studied cells in the visual cortex.
So, that was a virgin territory.
And so we had no hypothesis,
no real theory of how it should work.
We just wanted to,
using the method of recording from single nerve cells in the brain,
then try to see how the system works.
So, a simple-minded idea.
And we were very fortunate
in that we were able to come to the laboratory
of Stephen Kuffler,
who was already at the time...
he was working...
his lab was in the basement of the Wilmer Institute
at Johns Hopkins Medical School,
and it was a simple setup
and we got a room there.
And the reason why we were happy in the basement
was that Stephen Kuffler was a brilliant person
in his work
and his main interest was in synaptic transmission,
how the synapse, the connection between nerve fibers
and nerve cells,
work.
It's a very fine... and that was his passion,
but since he was at an eye institute, he also started...
did some work on the retina.
He recorded from single retinal ganglion cells.
And this was a fundamental work
that I will describe in the bit,
that really laid the foundation
for the work that David and I carried out in...
started out in the basement.
So, David Hubel, he...
he was Canadian and he had...
and he had already shown his talent in neuroscience.
He was working in [unknown]
and then during this period
he developed the micro-electrode,
the tungsten micro-electrode,
which was really a major advance.
And I had heard him giving talks about having
recorded from wide-awake cats
using a very elegant technique that he developed himself,
but actually later on was the model for
the work that is now still going on,
recording from wide-awake monkeys, in particular.
And he was very skillful in terms of instrumentation.
He had a lathe in the lab
and could build his own equipment.
So, I think, for me,
to have not only such a skillful technical ability
but also a brilliant mind for a person to work with
was, I think, my great fortune in my scientific career.
So, the combination of Kuffler and David
really set me off in a very good start.
The ummm... the ummm...
this is a picture of the micro-electrode
-- you can see the thing coming in from the right --
and coming close to a nerve cell.
The nerve cell is stained here with a silver stain
to show the cell body and the processes.
And it turns out, when you put the electrode close,
as we can see here, to the cell body,
you can record the all-or-none action potentials
that cells, nerve cells,
use to communicate with each other.
So, this all-or-none action potential
travels down a long process called an axon,
that then goes to another nerve cell
and communicates with that.
So, the frequency...
the action potential is an all-or-none signal
that changes in frequency and depending...
the information that's conveyed from one cell to another
is in the changes in the frequency of the firing of the cell.
And once the signal comes to the end of the axon,
the terminal,
the transmitter is released
and you then have an analog transformation
of the digital signal.
So, that's how the nervous system works.
The digital signaling over long or short distances,
and then an analog,
who would process the signal from, perhaps, thousands and thousands
of individual inputs to the cell.
So, this sounds very complicated,
but it turns out that, as we will see in the recording
that I will show,
that you actually can receive information,
useful information, by this recording.
And just to give you a little bit of a background,
let me show you ummm... the ummm...
system that we used.
In our studies, initially, we were in the...
as I said, in the basement,
and we had...
we had very little money
and the only thing we had available was this blackboard
and also an old slide projector
that we could put in,
and then we had an amplifier
and the animal was sitting behind David
and could look at the screen,
and then we'd project images onto the small papers
that you see tagged onto the blackboard.
And this was then our method of
stimulating the receptive field,
the light-sensitive area of single cells.
It might be easier to understand this
by looking at this graph.
This is a human head...
so, we only worked on anesthetized cats and monkeys,
but the system is very similar in man
and, in particular, in the monkey.
So, here you can see the eye,
and the person here is looking at the screen,
and you can see the squares on the screen,
and the eye then projects to the relay nucleus,
the retinal ganglion project,
and then this relay nucleus
projects to the visual cortex,
which is the two circles.
So, the first circle is the relay nucleus
and the big circle is the primary visual cortex.
And David and I, we spent about 20 years
trying to understand how this beautiful structure worked.
Now, the ummm...
one thing it's important to remember is that...
even if there are a million fibers
coming in from the eye to the relay nucleus
and then there are hundreds of millions of cells
in the primary visual cortex,
but even if there are these large numbers of cells,
you can still, by looking at one cell at a time,
you will, as you can see,
you will learn a great deal about how the system works.
And some people have said that, David and I,
we broke the code about how visual information
was processed from the eye and then by the brain.
So, we... or, I... I'd now like to...
so, keep in mind that a given cell
can only see one of the squares,
what we call the light-sensitive area
or the receptive field of a cell.
And you can see that here...
you see the horizontal bar...
so, a single cell can see that,
which we call, then, the receptive field,
the light-sensitive area.
The ummm...
the film you're going to hear, it sounds...
when you put the electrode close to the nerve cell
for the action potential,
the all-or-none signal,
there's an amplifier connected, so you can hear a plop
when the cell sends the signal.
And it's the frequency of these plops
that you will hear that indicate the signal.
So, you're now going to hear the signal
from one single nerve cell,
first from the relay nucleus
and then from the cortical cell.
And another thing you need to know is that
when Stephen Kuffler recorded from retinal ganglion cells,
he showed that they responded
very well to small spots of light,
but not to bit spots,
because they have a sensitive center
and an antagonistic surround.
So, by stimulating a bit spot, you antagonize a cell as well as exciting it,
so it's not as effective as just stimulating the center.
Now, David and I found that
the cells in the relay nucleus, here,
have the same properties: they like small spots,
but not big spots.
So, so... and then you will see,
when you record from cells, here, in the primary visual cortex,
we found that they don't respond
to small spots alike.
It was very frustrating,
and it was only by chance that
we discovered what you will see in the movie in a few...
in a second.
So, first, in the movie, you will hear the recording
from a single cell
in the lateral geniculate nucleus body,
and then, without transitioning, you'll hear a difference in the pitch of the sound
when you record from the cells
in the primary visual cortex.
So... so, here we stimulate,
now, in the center of that square,
which is the receptive field/sensitive area of the cell,
and you can hear a strong response.
Okay, now... here you can see, then,
the cell responds very well to small spots of light...
we make the spot large
and it's less effective
-- it's not as crisp as before.
And the reason is, as you can show here,
that you're stimulating... the surround is antagonistic.
The cell stops firing and when you turn it off it fires.
Okay.
And so you can see this antagonism
functions by contracting
-- have a big spot that you contract to a small spot, and then cell fires,
because you take away the inhibition.
It's just showing the center and surround arrangement
that Kuffler was the first to show in retinal ganglion cells,
but this is a geniculate cell.
Now, we go... just to show that this is
a circular and symmetric kind of organization
of the receptive field,
and to show that we have this bar
move across the receptive field
in different orientations.
And you can hear that
there's no real difference in the frequency of the impulses from...
we're still recording from a single nerve cell
in the relay nucleus.
Now, we have suddenly a pitch change,
and you can hear that,
and now we are recording from a single cell
in the primary visual cortex.
And we map out the light-sensitive area,
the receptive field,
of a single cortical cell.
And you can see...
the blackboard we had before...
it's very simple
and you can draw on this piece of paper the outline,
and the size of the field
is a little bit bigger than indicated here
and the orientation is a little bit counterclockwise,
but in principle this is actually
an experiment that David and I carried out
some 50-60 years ago.
We just wanted to have it documented,
because at first people didn't believe us
that it was true that cells had this property
that you now would see.
Some cells...
this cell responded a little bit better to leftward movement than right,
and some cells responded
only to one direction,
and other cells prefer one over the other.
So, this is the critical point coming up now.
Keep in mind, we are stimulating the same visual area
in the cortex,
but this cell doesn't see a horizontal bar
-- it can only see a bar along the vertical.
So, this is nature's amazing picture,
and they...
by asking and exploring nature,
the brain told us about this trick.
Next, we just show a simple paintbrush,
just to show you how
strong and simple this system is,
to detect any orientation of any contour.
So, the... I'd like to go back, now,
to this diagram,
just to point out that,
within the receptive...
the area of the receptive field, the light-sensitive area,
the cell you just saw
prefers sort of close to vertical orientation.
Now, when David and I first discovered this...
by chance, actually, it wasn't because we were clever...
it just happened that the contour of a...
of this orientation happened to pass by and we said,
"Oh, what does this mean?"
We couldn’t activate the cell with spots of light,
so David, who was very...
he rushed down the hall and called on our colleagues
to come and say, "Look what we have found!"
And so everybody came and were amazed, like we were,
about the specificity with which this cell responded
-- preferring one orientation over any other.
But within this square, here,
there are many...
there are other neighboring cells who prefer a different orientation.
In the drawing, here, we have a horizontal,
and there are other weak orientations.
Perhaps there is a representation of 20 different orientations,
but the cells...
all these cells see the same little area,
so you have to think about our visual system
as partialized into small light-sensitive areas,
and then it's not until you get into higher visual areas
when these areas come together,
and you have bigger areas of light sensitivity,
so you can see the whole world.
But the initial step in the processing of visual information
is this partialization of images.
And the idea, here,
is that these cells sensitive for an orientation of a contour
are the instrument used by the brain to visualize...
to rec...
to make it possible for us to perceive any object.
This slide is from a book by the late David Marr,
who was a...
he liked the idea about...
he was more a model builder, and he said that...
if you look at a teddy bear,
and you have these cells sensitive to orientation or contour,
and he drew, here, to the right, the...
here is a vertically oriented cell
preferring the top of the head...
so, you can actually draw the teddy bear
using these very simple cells.
So, that was the concept that...
it's like having a Lego set in your camp,
and you can look upon these cells as individual pieces,
that then the brain can use
in order to detect any object of interest.
Now, the funny thing happened
when we published this paper in the spring of 1969,
not this figure but the fact that the visual...
primary visual cortex is sensitive...
the cells there are sensitive to orientation of contours.
I received a note, or we received a note,
from John Z Young,
who was a very prominent neurobiologist in Britain,
and he said,
"Torsten, this is very nice, but it's nothing new,"
and then he sent me this picture of Van Gogh's self-portrait.
So, you can... as you can see,
Van Gogh gives oriented lines in order to draw his picture,
and other artists have also used similar ways,
and so you can ask,
maybe artists have a more intuitive understanding of how our brain works,
and they obviously don't realize it,
and we don't either, necessarily,
but this is one way, perhaps, that we should...
like to bring the arts and sciences together,
that by working together we may learn from each other.
So, the ummm... so, this... this was ummm...
the one discovery...
when we started out in September 1958,
we discovered the orientational cell sensitivity...
specificity of cortical cell orientation
after three months,
and so we quickly wrote a paper
and then published in the spring.
The point to come back to this slide is that...
to remind you that this discovery
is critically important for our understanding how vision...
how the visual information is coded,
but done with very simple...
two young guys using very simple tools.
And that...
like to inspire young people to,
if you have an idea,
just find out what you can do with it,
and then go out and try it out
and then once you find something that works,
you can get the resources and become...
build the proper laboratory, which we did.
So, David and I continued to work.
This, as I said, took a very short time,
and later we spent 20 years together.
David was supposed to come, as I mentioned, one month...
one year while his lab in Mountcastle was renovated,
but we got along so well
and so we stayed together and collaborated for 20 years,
and during those 20 years we did...
studied the cortical architecture,
we studied... showed that the orient...
cells with similar orientation
are grouped in columnar organization
in a very beautiful way,
and that the two eyes work together in a very precise way,
also in a columnar fashion.
And we could show, also, that the development of the visual system,
what we are both with
and how that can be modified by the environment.
So, this is along story,
but the fact that we had the resources and time,
but it just started out very simply...
I think this is... we'll remember.
Of course, we then, in 1981,
we were told that we had won the Nobel Prize,
so this is just a press conference in that context
and we both looked happy.
Now, David continued to stay at Harvard until 2013,
when he died,
and I still feel strongly that...
I used to call...
we used to call each other scientific brothers, and that's true.
We became, scientifically, very close
and enjoyed each other scientifically,
whereas at the same time we had our own personal lives.
But it was a real brotherhood-type...
scientific brotherhood situation.
So, I still miss the guy.
So, thank you.